[Music]  nba playoffs getting pretty exciting huh  yeah  you know what's even more exciting  though to me i'll be honest with you the  clothes  that the nba stars have been wearing at  their post-game  press conferences  yeah i mean we showed some of these uh  last night but i i want to show more  because they're really getting pretty  daring take a look  i just wanted to win this game real bad  i just knew we needed this game i think  we really opened up  everybody with cb you know he's starting  off shooting the ball the way he did  three months um without any um adversity  just not what we used to we felt sure  that the series was tied two-two we just  went on a run we went in the car they  were not able to stop it you just gotta  go back to the drawing board and  you know see where we're going  yeah it was really bad  but you know what it's not the rest  every every game's in the game  [Music]  [Applause]